it's the week nine power rankings we're
anticipating how these teams as they're
currently configured are going to
interact when it's time to play their
next games number one
pittsburgh steelers for the second
straight week i didn't think they'd last
very long i thought they'd lose the
ravens but there they are at number one
the chiefs holding steady at number two
there was some movement because the
titans lost and the ravens lost and the
seahawks won and they jumped up and the
bucks won and the saints won and so we
see some
activity and you know it's look at it
every team except the steelers and the
chiefs had movement in the top half
right so uh you know some some outcomes
from this week influencing me but let's
stay with the two that didn't move
because
my good friend my on-air partner i can
always count on you to have my back
last night these aren't mine
some guy comes at you and says why do
you have the chiefs behind the steelers
and your knee-jerk reaction is sorry
these aren't mine don't blame me
thank you well i i i mean every week
when you release the power rankings i
see a few tweets where people
they get mad at me
so
i i finally had enough last night as i
go through it and i just sit there and i
go i finally said wait i'm chris sims
i'm not pft these are his rankings i am
a co-host on pft four days a week but
mike florio is pft
and okay
yes uh i wanted to stir the pot a little
bit because oh you did we're i'm i want
i need you're gonna have to you're gonna
change this before the day is over i'm
gonna get you to check i'm not yes you
are you know
if the dealer's doing it
well yeah i know because you're stubborn
as hell obviously you're in your house
doing a show in west virginia okay but
i you know you would pick the chiefs to
beat the pittsburgh steelers in a
one-game playoff right now
i know
i don't think you would mike florio the
guy who
i know is scared to pick against patrick
mahomes
waxes poetically about him all the time
talks about the chiefs when they raise
up to a level and they're awoken with a
team that scares them a little bit and
then you watch the damn raven steelers
game on on you we watched it on monday
on film you yourself said how the hell
did the steelers win that game
so that counselor i will rest my case
and make the change
all right now no no okay
here here's here i got a question for
you okay chris and we've got on the
screen the poll question that you you
tweeted a question we'll discuss on pft
live who would win this matchup if they
played tomorrow chiefs
70.9 steelers 29.1 percent
let's i and i want you to be
candid with me yes if we had done that
same
poll last week and it was raven steelers
what do you think the spread would have
been
of people who would have thought the
ravens would beat the steelers yeah that
would have been i think that it would
have been probably about
i'm going to say 60 40 55 45 ravens over
steelers right and the steelers won i
mean i
when when i was in the lab last
wednesday night
picking games and i picked the steelers
to win 27-24 the closest i've had to a
hole-in-one all season picking the the
actual final score of the game which was
28 24
i look my my
everything in my brain
said the ravens are going to win this
game
but we all know and this is where
you know analytics reaches the water's
edge and statistical understanding and
looking at film and past results etc
there's that visceral
sense
that there's something about this
steelers team there's something about
them finding a way they just find a way
every week they've found a way
and that would
i'm not saying i would definitely pick
the steelers if it was steelers chiefs i
will be honest since i guess i am under
oath here and i will tell the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
i probably would lean heavily toward the
chiefs but
just like you know the move is not final
until you take your hand off the the
checker i
i i would be
reminded of the steelers uncanny ability
to find ways to win
and uh i hope i hope to have that
dilemma i hope the steelers and the
chiefs meet at some point in january
well i do too that would be i mean that
would be awesome certainly i mean really
but yeah i just
uh i mean i get what you're saying i get
it and they do have a little bit of the
factor of like hey we're just gonna get
it done it might not always look that
way or whatever but
man oh man
i'm not picking against number 15 and
red
or the chiefs in any big football game
anytime soon i'm really not they just
deliver too much for for my money that
way and
um okay all right so i'll and let me say
this yeah i say this let me say this
because i'm going to get flooded with
emails and tweets saying of course you
feel that way because you're a steelers
fan look i grew up 60 miles from
pittsburgh i was never a steelers fan i
had to be a contrarian i had to be
different trust me i wish i hadn't been
a contrarian the 70s would have been a
magical decade for me with four super
bowl championships i regret that i had
to go
in a different path from what oh you got
to be a steelers fan chris you know me
well enough you know what my reaction
would be even at eight years old no i
don't well we just heard i don't and i
said you had to change your ranking you
said well you don't know me because
you're the st you're one of the most
stubborn people i know yeah yeah but uh
but but it's i but but i've been in and
around pittsburgh for almost all of my
life there's something about this
organization and it look they've they've
only won only six i mean it matches the
patriots but i this just feels like a
year
where
it's just working and it's going to work
and whoever it is that they're playing
you know i'm not saying they're going to
go undefeated but
when when it's winner take all the
seasons riding on it i i think this is a
team that you you want to be very
careful about picking again well i i
agree with that i do and i don't think
there's any team in football that can
just come in and
you know control the pittsburgh steelers
like no matter who it is they're going
to be in the football game i would agree
with that too there's certainly
i mean yeah i'm saying the chiefs are
one they're number two that's all i'm
trying to say that's all i was trying to
say now i want to get to the next part
because the next part i think you move
the ravens too far down
i think i would i i think i would have
made the ravens number three i really
would the fact that they lost that game
to the steelers and they lost the game
to the chiefs
and
yes i think the way hey listen the
seahawks are really good that's a really
close one but i'm just saying i probably
would have made the ravens three and the
seahawks four and then i'm cool with
really everything you have there the
rest of the top ten
you know why i put them down as far as i
did yeah why
because there is some sort of
organizational defect that pops up when
they play the elite teams yeah and it's
not just the chiefs being the ravens
kryptonite they've got
an elite team kryptonite issue
and not that the titans are an elite
team but look at what happened in the
playoffs last year when they come up
against these great teams and and i saw
somebody trying to make the argument
that lamar jackson is is owen six
against great teams or something like
that well they did beat the hell out of
the rams last year
they did beat seattle and seattle and
they did beat the 49ers at home too
and the patriots right yeah and and they
they burst the bubble of the patriots
last year when they were unbeaten when
they beat the seahawks last year that
was the moment that we started to say
maybe the ravens have something but when
they steamrolled the rams on a monday
night november of last year that's when
they started to feel like a team of
destiny but but i just still feel like
there's something missing there
and and i think that what happened on
sunday
exposed it a little bit more to outplay
your opponent that dramatically and
still lose
you know on one hand you can say ah it's
a fluke it's an aberration it's an
anomaly forget about it i don't know
that it's as easily forgotten because i
think you get to a point where you got
guys in the locker room were thinking
what the hell do we have to do to win
games like this right if they beat if
they beat the titans and the steelers in
a few weeks from now you know would that
change your thought at least on that oh
absolutely it will okay i know i know
iso isn't sure still like you know oh
they get to the playoffs will that be i
mean we're still going to have the
questions there and all that but you
know i think this week is still going to
be a pretty good test for them you know
balto i mean the baltimore the old
baltimore the indianapolis colts they
can play some defense and i would think
they are going to
somewhat be able to
hold the run game with the ravens in
check a little i i wouldn't expect it to
be able to 250 type yar 250 rushing
yards this week i think this scheme
might be a little bit more effective as
far as stopping lamar jackson in the run
game and i think this will be another
game that's going to be very important
where we're going to go
wait i think lamar jackson in the past
game is going to have to be as equally
effective as the run game is for them to
win the game you know i i will be
surprised if they can just steamroll the
the indianapolis colts defense and run
them over with a
healthy defensive front and darius
leonard back in the fold and all those
type of things so that'll be interesting
to see how they react this week coming
off this loss
all right the next two teams in the
power rankings
present a similar
dilemma seahawks at three
buccaneers at four who would win if they
played tomorrow tyson roderick on
twitter says i'd put the bucks over the
seahawks same kind of high scoring
offense and the bucks have a better
defense and you know what
i would have put the buccaneers over the
seahawks if they didn't look like crap
on monday night against the giants
that's their punishment for not covering
the spread chris we both picked them to
come oh my god i'm on three for my best
bets last week i hadn't even thought of
that with all the election anxiety oh
and three thanks for the reminder pete
pete takes an unusual amount of glee
in
yes he does in when when we have a rough
week he's got this passive aggressive
way of being very gleeful about it never
says crap and again i almost said that
other word when we have a great week but
when we stumble he just loves it oh he
loves to send that text and emails
doesn't he he loves it oh rough week for
you guys
[Laughter]
all right so uh i i think that
i think the buccaneers probably would
beat the seahawks but i was pissed that
the bucks didn't cover
and and they did they did screw around
with the giants more than they should
have so they had to they they had to see
the seahawks leapfrog them that was my
that was my decision yeah i have no
issue with that i don't you know again i
i
it's a close one it certainly is
um
i do think that tampa is
yeah a more well-rounded football team i
do that do i think they can necessarily
win right now this moment no i think
that's very close i'm not going to argue
that i think they have a greater
potential to be a better team as it
looks right now
you know eight nine weeks from now i
think that's where i really look at
tampa to be you know can i sit in here
and say brady
you know and that defense is good as it
is is it gonna slow down dk and russell
wilson and company i don't know you know
and then seattle yeah i don't expect
them to be able to slow down tampa
either this would be the type of offense
that seattle would really struggle with
because oh wait we have to defend the
run they're pretty big up front they can
overpower us and then they have a great
passing scheme let alone the talent
around with it to where i think it would
be some sort of type of shootout type
football game but i'm cool with you
there right now i get that i mean
seattle
has lost one game and they outplayed the
team they lost to
and really
you know we're a little unlucky to lose
that game against arizona so even though
all their games have been close and
everything like that there's still
something to say about like what you
said about pittsburgh they just seem to
find a way to get it done all the time
and there is something to that
and let me say this for the same reasons
i look forward to the steelers and the
chiefs crossing paths in january please
give me
a tom brady russell wilson elimination
game right right any round i don't care
when yeah in fact i'd i'd almost rather
it not be for a super bowl berth i'd
rather it be because it would be an
amazing game whenever it's played i'm
fine with it being divisional round yeah
but either way give me russell wilson
versus tom brady uh super bowl 49
rematch with uh
with one of the quarterbacks on a very
different team and a team arguably as
good as any team he's been on over the
course of the past decade in new england
all right
uh number 12 the miami dolphins up six
spots the highest riser of the week
and i i had to give them credit for what
they did to a very good rams team
it deserved that bump and we need to
take them seriously how serious of a
contender are they though i know that we
need to see more from tonga by loa
but the
the first piece of evidence
did not cause anyone to say oh wow they
got a keeper in tour no it did not now
the game just didn't lend itself that
way you know not that he
he didn't do he you know he didn't do
great he didn't do poor he just did what
he had to do in this game to kind of win
the football game he really only made
two throws the whole game
you know it was the slant for a
touchdown which was a great throw it
showed you his quick release you know
he's got really damn good feet in the
pocket that's the one thing that jumps
out too he's got he can hop and bounce
around and he made that throw kind of
hopping backwards and through a great
throw there was a comeback to the right
side other than that it was all screens
and dump offs and things like that so i
don't know what to expect from them i do
know
miami has a lot of pieces that are very
impressive
let alone they're coached well
and it is just going to be about you
know how far along tua is
can they still implement and do all the
same things offensively that they were
doing with ryan fitzpatrick you know
they figured out their offensive line
you know these two receivers they got on
the outside as far as devonta parker and
um i'm blanking on the other guy's name
oh damn it's killing me here um he's a
good damn player who's the other
receiver
um down in uh
miami yeah i guess it's i guess it's
preston williams yes i'm i'm blanking it
but you got those two guys so there's
things to like so especially with that
defense but i don't know how good to say
they really are mike until we just see
the offense under tua and how good he
can be and can he make plays and protect
the ball and do all those type of things
richard lutz1468 wants to know whether
or not the dolphins are a sneaky playoff
team look with seven spots i i could see
them making it chris i don't think
that's crazy at all yeah they're four
and three right now four and three and
they some of their losses you know i
mean they had to deal with cam newton
and the new offense in new england week
one
they were right there to take the game
from seattle on a very close football
game so
yeah i think they are a sneaky playoff
team and i mean when you look at
cleveland who right now is the number
seven seed
i mean what's to make you think that
cleveland's gonna beat miami in a
head-to-head matchup i'm not so sure i
would probably take miami really i would
definitely take miami it was ryan
fitzpatrick right now i just go i'm not
sure because i just want to see more
from tua but
you know i i think there's a lot of
playoff-ish type things about that
dolphins football team
yeah i don't disagree with that at all
and look if the patriots are going to
fade as they seem to be doing it does
create a spot for someone else to rise
up and step up and maybe it will be the
dolphins who replaced the patriots on
the afc playoff tree the raiders at
number 14 up two spots after they beat
the browns in cleveland on sunday
they've had a tough schedule and madden
god 24 i guess that would be madden god
24 i can read uh he says weird the
raiders beat two of your top five teams
well they did beat two of the top five
teams in the power rankings they've
beaten the saints who's the other top
five team that they beat all the chiefs
by the way the number two team or as
chris would say the number one team but
they also got blown off the field by the
tampa bay buccaneers right the raiders
are just inconsistent
and and i don't know what to make of
them any given week i don't know which
raiders team is going to show up you
need to start stringing wins together
but if you hang around 500 you have a
shot at that seventh seat we're going to
learn something week 11 when they host
the kansas city chiefs because they have
to have the opportunity to complete the
sweep
of the team you would say is the best in
football
and uh you know
this there are winnable games
they should beat the chargers they
should beat the broncos they should beat
the falcons they should beat the jets
that's four more wins right there that's
eight and then the rest of the way
chargers broncos you complete those
sweeps you got 10 wins this is a team
that should be in the mix for a playoff
birthday yeah they though that's what
they are they're a borderline football
team i don't look at them as any threat
in any way to go make a run of the super
bowl or anything like that but you know
they're they're another one of these
teams that we've talked about over the
last few weeks where they just go
they're a match-up football team
you know it depends on the match up to
how they're going to be able to play i
mean you've seen that you know any time
you know they they have issues on their
roster as far as the defensive side of
the ball especially
you know and when a team is balanced on
offense they have a hard time stopping
it now they matched up well with
cleveland last week because cleveland
you know if they can't run the ball
their offense is offensively challenged
and that's good you know those are the
type of teams
they
produce against right now but yeah i'm
not sure exactly how good the raiders
football team is the one thing they do
is they're tough they can run the
football that gives them a great
advantage their defense they got some
good cover guys
but other than that they really don't
have anything else and i would think
that yes next time they play kansas city
who's ever since they played the raiders
have shown a lot more versatility in
their offense and ways they can beat you
they'll be ready for some of the things
the raiders did to them the first time
and they won't be asleep at the wheel
and take it for granted and i think
they'll probably end up putting the
raiders back in back in their place that
way but i do expect the raiders to be in
this conversation like you said
let's look at the back half of the power
rankings
the eagles up four spots to number 17.
how encouraging was that win over the
cowboys chris because there wasn't a
whole lot in it to look at and say wow
hey they've turned the corner but the
reality is they're in the nfc east so
there isn't really a corner to turn no
there's not and i don't feel any better
i mean honestly after a game like that
you i feel worse i mean i do you just go
i mean what at what point are they they
going to start playing good football at
least just good football to where they
don't screw it up and then carson wentz
of course was a big part of that i know
that
you know so yeah i mean he's an issue
and the fact that he just can't reign it
in at times and continues to make really
really stupid mistakes there's no other
way to say that
but i don't think that's gonna totally
just
fix itself
right now because
one they need him to
you know tote the line of danger
as far as making plays and not doing
that because they can't they don't have
anybody that can make a play on their
offense
and i don't know if that'll change until
they get some guys back and healthy and
take a little pressure off him that way
but there are some things about their
team to like and go oh if they win the
nfc east and they get healthy
they could be a pain in the butt for
some team they have to play in the
playoffs they're not going to just be
able to team that i look at you're just
going to be able to roll over and go
we're going to win it's the nfc east
winner the eagles no chance i i don't
see it that way i still think they're
they got a little fight and something
something to be said there
we're never going to get you to stop
saying tote the line are we no i'm just
not i'm just not even going to try
anything you know what's crazy except
the fact that it's an appropriate term
even if it isn't thank you i think i
just go with it just this is the
citizenship and that's just the way it
is
okay a couple more real quick because
can we put that graphic back up the
market was very volatile this week my
goodness when i look at it now i wonder
uh
about my sanity and or sobriety when i
was putting it together but there are
reasons for every one of these moves
and i said that the
uh the dolphins were the highest risers
i gave the vikings a bump after beating
the packers on the road of seven spots
yeah and you know what based on the way
they played this past weekend they
deserve to be at number 20 chris i don't
know if they can keep it up and
basically it's an elimination game this
weekend against the lions who fell four
spots after losing to the colts
convincingly whoever wins that game
still has a shot at maybe getting lucky
and getting hot down the stretch whoever
wins that game has that opportunity ever
loses is done are you back on the
bandwagon
no
damn the annulment the annulment's still
pending all right so are you just gonna
join the steelers fandom finally and
make up for the mistake you messed up
with in the 70s
no no no no what i'm doing is i'm
enjoying a football season that for a
long time i worried would not happen or
would be incomplete and i'm still
worried we're not gonna get 256 regular
season games so i'm just trying to enjoy
every moment enjoy every day enjoy every
second of working with someone like you
and and however it plays out it plays
out they'll crown a champion they'll
shoot the confetti and then we move on
to the next season that's how i'm
looking at it but um yeah how about the
bengals at 19.
they're two five and one i love joe
burrow i love his confidence i love the
swagger is there a way is there a way
that they can maybe
maybe
i mean they've been swapped by the
browns i know i don't think one of those
games against cleveland right i know i
don't think so i think that
they'll play some playoff caliber teams
here down the stretch and be a pain in
the butt for them i do because he just
he's he's a hell of a player
and listen they've fixed her they've
figured out their defense a little bit
too to least aware that just doesn't get
crushed anymore and they can make some
stops and they got some cover guys and
good safeties in the back end so they're
a little bit better that way but yeah
burrow gives them a fighting chance
because
he's so smart he's so accurate
he's really like a veteran as far as his
decisions and getting the ball out of
his hands and not putting the team in
bad positions and then of course he
makes plays when nothing is there
i mean more times than not
it still ends up being there because joe
makes it happen well i mean there was a
lot of plays last week in that game
where i went nothing's there there's not
one guy open
the pass protection's not that great and
here he goes moving around and making
some damn throw and you just go well
okay first down bangles let's go and uh
that's where he's going to be a pain in
the butt for some of these teams coming
down the stretch
he's never going to concede anything
this year and he's going to continue to
believe that the bengals have a chance
even when they're mathematically
eliminated and all of that is going to
serve them well in the future as soon as
next year these growing pains now i
think are going to make them even better
and they're a team that we just already
need to kind of circle for 2021
depending upon what they do in the draft
what they do in free agency yeah and
borough may be a guy who attracts other
players to come to cincinnati and want
to be part of it right they could have
something special going in cincinnati so
maybe maybe as i look for a new favorite
team maybe the bengals are going to get
some consideration if they just get rid
of that damn helmet they would be a more
attractive option i'm with you don't get
me started on their damn uniforms i've
been saying that forever they need a
rebrand
real quickly is the terminator dead i
don't think i've ever had the patriots
at 23. i they probably weren't at 17
as of last week are they done i don't
i'm not gonna say they're done they're i
mean they're on their last like lifeline
i mean if they're a nine cat they're a
cat with nine lives they've lost eight
of them i mean they really have there's
very little room for error you know they
do have a chance here
to make a run you know other than the
ravens coming up on their schedule the
rest of the games where i wouldn't say
their favorites i still can go oh they
can beat that football team
so you look at the jets the ravens the
texans the cardinals the chargers the
rams
i i mean hey i wouldn't be shocked if
they went on some sort of four out of
the next five type win i'm not going to
count them out completely yet i'm not
i'm not expecting it but i still think
they're going to have one more push or
one more say
in this thing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports